hey guys it's max in this video we're
going to be comparing the brand new
airpods max
to the bose 700s and not only are we
going to compare the active noise
cancellation
we're also going to take a look at
things like the ambient mode we're going
to talk about comfort
we're going to listen to audio and
compare them in multiple different
genres
and even some uncompressed super high
quality audio
playing both wired we're gonna test
latency microphone quality
and much more the first thing that i
notice is the difference
in weight the airpods max weigh about 50
more than the bose and it is fairly
significant
and you definitely notice that weight
difference if you're going outside on a
walk and especially if you try
running with these the heft and extra
weight really kind of bounces on your
head
with the airpods max but with that said
i think most people are going to be on
airplanes sitting in office chairs
things like that not really using them
in active environments as far as comfort
when you're sitting down i did use both
of these
and they're very unique with the airpods
max you have this top band with this
really stretchable material and it
pretty much
makes the headband kind of disappear
when you put them on over the head
you kind of just don't feel it at all
whereas with the
bose headphones the band is fairly soft
but it's rubbery
and you definitely notice it when you
put them on you always feel the headband
right on the top of your head with that
said the bows do have
quite a bit less pressure as far as the
ear cups
around your ears so it's a different
feeling as far as the padding both these
are
very soft softer than the sony's that i
own so that part of it is good
and as far as long-term comfort i did
feel a little bit more comfortable in
the airpods max but i haven't used them
for an extended period of time just yet
i'm gonna use them for a full day and
i'll talk about that in my full detailed
review so make sure you click that
subscribe button below if you guys want
to check that out
as far as adjustability i like that both
of them have these
telescopic arms so you don't have a
standard kind of clicked
design so you can get it exactly how you
want
and the bose they don't adjust in the
band just the actual cups themselves
move
but it's still really nice and has a
good amount of tension so it's not going
to accidentally adjust
as far as build quality the airpod max
are definitely ahead
they're built out of solid aluminum
that's cnc'd out for the ear cups here
and then you have stainless steel for
the headband
that is rubberized these definitely are
the most premium feeling headphones that
i've ever held
with that said the bose don't feel cheap
they are plastic
and then you have this metal headband
over here they definitely feel nicer
than most headphones on the market and i
would not choose the airpods max
just because of build quality one area
the bose smokes the airpods max
is the case we have this smart case that
apple gave us
and you open it up you slip these in
here that gives you access to the
charging point with this and you have
this magnetic kind of flap here
but i hate the way it looks i hate that
you have to put these in here to power
them down
automatically and probably the worst
thing is how much of this aluminum is
exposed
so if you toss these in a bag in a
backpack you can still get this
scratched up and dinged up which
really sucks and then i'm also kind of
worried about this
soft headband it getting cut or frayed
i don't like that bose has a really nice
case it's very slim
it's protective but it's not big and
then you can open it up we have this
nice little
magnetic compartment for your cables yes
they do
include a three and a half mil cable
it's fairly lightweight
and it's nice and protective so you pop
it in throw it in your backpack
you have no worries and now i want to
clear up a misconception with the
airpods max
apple just put out a statement today and
they said that if you're not using him
with the case
and you just leave your airpods max on
the table like this
after about five minutes they will go
into low power mode
whereas with the case they go into low
power mode instantly
and then if you don't touch it for a
couple days then they'll go into ultra
low power mode
where in the case it takes 18 hours to
go into that state so you don't have to
use the case
and you don't lose out on that much
battery life if you don't end up using
it which i haven't been
and now let's talk about controls the
bose have a couple buttons over here if
you want to use your smart assistant or
you want to toggle between the active
noise cancellation we have a bluetooth
pairing button
and we actually have a touch surface on
the right ear cup right here now it's a
little bit small
because it's just on the right side of
the band
but it actually is very responsive much
better than the sony xm3s and xm4s
so it does work the airpods max on the
other hand just have physical controls
we have a toggle
to go between your active noise
cancellation and your transparency mode
and we have this digital crown now
personally i
am a huge fan of that digital crown
because you can just lift up your hand
you can turn them up turn them down you
can press once or multiple times to do
different functions so far it's been
working really well as far as battery
life both of these are rated at 20 hours
with
active noise cancellation and i think
both bose
and apple under-rated them the sound
guys gave the bose about 22 hours in
their 75 decibel test they haven't yet
tested the airpods max
but they do seem like they're better and
then you can turn off the active noise
cancellation
as well if you want more battery life
and both could be topped up
really quickly and now let's get into
how they perform we're gonna start out
with
noise cancellation and i'm going to
start out testing how they perform
with the active noise cancellation
turned off just to see how much noise
they block out passively
and as you guys could see you actually
can toggle them to off mode
and the airpods max block out a
substantial amount of sound
with not active cancellation not even on
we have a vent up there
and i could still hear it but a lot of
that sound is
gone probably the majority of it let's
check out the bose and i just have them
turned off right now so there's nothing
going on
okay yeah there definitely is a
difference so these cut out
probably 50 of that hvac noise
but i could definitely hear the low
rumble and a little bit of the higher
pitch
wind noise going through that vent so
not as good as the airpods max but let's
go ahead and turn them on and check out
the active noise cancellation
right away that noise is gone and it has
a nice little tone when you turn it on
it also tells you there's a little voice
assist that talks to you but the voice
sounds
terrible way worse than the sony's
wow okay so all the low end rumble is
gone
i still hear a little bit that higher
end hiss
and it's interesting because i know i'm
referring back to the sonys because i
just tested those and i have the xm3s
the sony's get rid of all the high end
the low end there's still a little bit
left still
very very good yeah it's definitely a
big difference there let's put these on
press the button all right
i hear my voice more so when i'm talking
than with the bose which is very
interesting
but that hvac noise and we have a
central furnace that's always on here
that is completely gone we don't have
any of the low and rumble
and none of the high frequency sounds as
well it definitely is
stronger as far as the active noise
cancellation let's take this
one step further i have some air
compressor sound here which is a mix of
different sounds
i'm going to turn it down a little bit
this time because in the last video i
don't know if you guys could even hear
me
that's how loud it was so i'm going to
hit play here set it down about three
feet in front of me
and i hear the different frequencies the
kind of modulation there
but it's definitely really quiet let me
take these off
oh yeah probably about 75 of that is
gone so that is impressive
let's go ahead and put the bose on okay
so these actually cancel out a little
bit more of that
low end sound but you still get more of
the high end sound
so wow that is actually closer than i
expected between these two
honestly i wouldn't buy one over the
other just for the differences in active
noise cancellation they are very close
overall the airpods max they do a better
job
but the difference isn't that
substantial i do want to add that the
bose does allow you
to customize how much active noise
cancellation you want
and if you toggle the button it'll
actually go to half active noise
cancellation and then your ambient mode
but i think for most people if you're
blocking it sound you want to block out
all of it so now let's go ahead and
compare the ambient or the transparency
modes on the bose you just turn off
active and it pumps and sound from
outside of you so let me press once and
then press twice okay
wow actually well my voice sounds a
little bit different
i sound i don't sound very digital which
is
interesting the ambient mode is pretty
good
i sound like i'm a little bit nasally
like if i just close my nose
but that vent sound sounds very true to
life
my voice just sounds a little bit off
angelica can you say something
you sound pretty natural let me go ahead
and lift this up
alright yeah so it's not as loud as the
actual environment is a little bit
quieter still
but the frequencies are pretty good
that man the ambient mode is definitely
way ahead
of the sony xm4s all right let's try out
the air paws
and press this once all right
yeah i mean if you guys look at any
reviews online these are killing it with
their transparency mode apple's done a
fantastic job
it sounds 99
as true to life the ambient mode is
definitely better than the bose
let me hear your voice as well you sound
identical
to real life or almost identical pretty
much there
the ambient mode is really good on the
airpods max
i don't know if that matters to you guys
or how much that matters
uh but these are ahead and now let's go
ahead and compare the microphones
i'm going to start out in this room
where we have a lot of the hvac noise
that needs to be canceled out
and then we're going to move to a much
much quieter room
this is the microphone quality of the
bose 700s in a fairly loud environment
and this is the quality of the airpods
max in a fairly loud
environment and now let's go into that
quiet room and test the microphones
there
this is the microphone quality of the
bose 700s in a really quiet room
and this is the microphone quality of
the airpods max in
a really quiet room alright guys let me
know your thoughts down in the comment
section below which one sounded better
in
the loud room versus the quiet room what
differences you noticed
let me know one thing i want to point
out is that i really like that the
bose as soon as you start recording even
with the third-party app
it gives you this little notification
like a little hum that kind of kicks in
and that way you know if any application
is using the microphones
that is pretty neat and now i want to
test out latency for those of you guys
that might want to play some
gaming using bluetooth or maybe some
video editing
how much delay is there i have call of
duty
mobile opened up right here i'm going to
switch through the menus here
and the airpods max they have about a
hundred milliseconds of delay
maybe up to 150 but about a hundred so
that is
very very good for bluetooth headphones
and that makes
things like video editing even though
you might notice the delay if you're
looking
for it still usable so definitely not
bad vadim did play a couple hours of
call of duty mobile and he said he had
no
issues let's go ahead and test out the
bose
all right i think these are actually
better than the sony's
or maybe close definitely more delay
yeah probably about a third of a second
or so 300 milliseconds
350. so you definitely will notice it
not as bad as some other headphones
which can go up to like 700 milliseconds
but definitely not as good as the
airpods max now of course you can use
both of these
wired the wire comes with the bose 700s
with the airpods max you have to spend
another 35
bucks and you can't use the little
adapter that came with your older iphone
i test it out it doesn't work
but with that said if you are wanting to
edit on the go or play games without a
cable
that's one area that you really can't
beat to the airpods max or the other
airpods
and now it's time to compare the sound
quality i went ahead and found the
tracks that i've been using in titles
we're gonna get
some better audio quality compared to
youtube i'm gonna go ahead and take a
listen you guys can hear
some of the song as well and i'll give
you guys my opinions
all right guys wow that was definitely
interesting there's a
couple big differences between these
first off i want to say that the bows
have really nice clarity and separation
between different
sounds a lot better than the sony's
now with that these actually get quite a
bit whoops
quite a bit louder than the airpods max
at full volume come on
ah there's no optical sensor in there
alright let's pause i just hit that
touch little touch sensor so yeah
there's no optical sensors here but man
these get
loud i had to turn them down and with
that i noticed that
at full blast the bass cannot keep up
you really start hearing the mids and
especially the highs
and then if you kick it down a notch or
two on the iphone which i ended up
having to do
then it sounds a lot more balanced but
at full blast it was just way too loud
anyways at least with high quality title
sound
now with that the bass on the airpods
max was still
quite a bit better it's a lot more rich
and the airpods max are right in between
the sonys which are a little too boomy
and the bose 700s but of course this is
an edm
song it's pretty easy to play this back
let's go ahead and listen to something
else
this song has some piano has some nice
bass some other instruments and it
really allows you to hear
the sound stage with different
headphones so let's take a listen
[Music]
all right guys very interesting once
again
uh that is a whole different sound
compared to the last
song first off this song was quieter
and i appreciated that i can get more
volume out of these i actually had a
maxed
out with the airpods max i try to turn
them up more so not that you really need
to with that noise cancellation but
i'm just a sucker for really loud sound
let me know if you're one of those
people
down in the comment section below and
the base here uh it was perfectly enough
i didn't really want any more
even though the airpods max it does have
more bass it still sounds good but i
didn't feel like it was lacking
what i felt was lacking was the richness
in the piano
notes i noticed that the most it just
sounded a little bit flat
whereas the airpods max sound really
nice and rich and with that
interestingly once again um the higher
little
i don't know what instrument that is
little hi-hats or something that's in
here
it didn't sound as crisp i guess not in
a bad way
it didn't stand out as much with the
bose whereas the previous song the
vocals were actually a little bit
more crisp with the bows and it sounded
nicer on the airpods max
and then the last thing is the sound
stage you could definitely tell that the
airpods max have a wider
sound stage so they definitely sounded
quite a bit
better than the bose a bigger difference
than with that edm
track and now let's make this even
tougher we're gonna listen to a rock
song
where we have so many different
instruments all being played very loud
and being mushed together and this test
has been the toughest
out of all of them that have done so far
so let's go ahead and start out
i see it coming
all right guys wow that is
another massive difference and just like
with the sony sorry i keep referring i
know this is not a comparison to the
sony's
this test is really where the airpods
max
really stand out if you're somebody
loves listening a rock metal
other genres where you have a lot of
instruments these things absolutely
destroy when you're listening in that
now
these didn't sound bad but there was one
major issue well maybe two
issues but one is an actual issue at
full blast
there is like some harshness or
distortion in the high frequencies
and in the vocals they just sound very
harsh
i had to turn them down i turned him
down by
one notch and then it seemed like it was
too quiet like there's a big jump
between full blast and one notch down i
try to turn it up
and it goes back up to full volume so
you can't run him
at full volume there now one interesting
thing that i noticed
is that they're right in the mess of all
the instruments which sounds good it's a
good mess
there's like a little violin in the
background i did not hear that with my
ear pods max with the sony's
i do hear them with these bows the
clarity is definitely
good but what i really missed once i
turned it down
is the richness in the base where you
can and also they can separate
um the the sound of the drums and the
bass guitar it kind of gets blended
together it's not very
rich and that is where the airpods max
have been doing an absolutely great job
not only does it sound rich but you can
separate
the different instruments that are all
very similar i guess in frequencies so
if you're somebody that listens to this
kind of music
wow that's a big difference and now
let's kick it up one
more level i have my macbook pro here
and we are listening to an
ultra high quality completely
uncompressed
song instead of playing back at 256
kilobit per second
with the bluetooth option we are at 8
400 this song is actually 563
megabytes it is massive so let's go and
take a listen and once again
shout out to hifi insider and m a
audiophilic recordings
for providing us with this really high
quality song
do
[Music]
all righty that was the final test
and that was actually a lot closer than
i expected now there were a few key
differences
the biggest one is probably sound stage
with the bose they're very similar to
sony's i feel like i'm
right around here as far as where the
sound is coming out with airpods max it
is
much wider probably twice as wide like
you're kind of sitting there we have
speakers
all around you and the piano did sound a
little bit more
rich but other than that they were very
close and
volume interestingly was also pretty
much
identical between the two it seems like
with the airpods i don't know if it's
just the eq
or the dsp whatever's happening here i
know they have mics that are facing in
that are adjusting everything constantly
to make sure there's no distortion
and in some songs it'll lower down the
volume to make sure there's no
distortion
where the bows don't do that but in
songs where there's less going on
it allows you to get louder especially
if you have a good quality source
and that they both sounded really good
now angelica did notice something else
um the airpods max do leak more sound
than the bose at least in some of these
last
songs that we were testing so that's
something that's very interesting and
i also noticed room noise with the bose
just like i do
uh with the airpods max whereas the
sony's i didn't the sony's
really didn't do good they distorted in
the song sorry that i keep bringing
those up but i just tested those
yesterday
and overall as far as sound quality i
will have to say
i'm impressed with the bose yes the
sound stage isn't as good
but the separation of different
instruments other than in rock genres
it's really good the clarity is good
um they do a great job maybe you'd want
a little more bass but you could
probably eq that in
i'm impressed with these but overall the
airpods max
they do sound better and they sound
great all around with a bunch of genres
do they sound 150 to 200 dollars better
uh depending on the price for the bose
when you're watching this video
i don't know i think it really depends
on what you want to
listen to if you're listening to rock or
if you're listening to
something that has a lot of bass i would
say probably
if you're listening to stuff that's more
like classical then probably not and of
course you can add a little bit more
bass to these
so that is subjective but i guess if
you're taking a look at the overall
picture and you are an ios user
you're getting a lot with these
headphones you're getting siri support
you're getting announced messages you
can quickly switch between your devices
pretty much
instantly along with that you have
spatial audio which i didn't cover in
this video
the bose don't have any surround sound
at all and
apple does an absolutely phenomenal job
with their spatial audio so if you want
to watch movies the experience is
incredible you won't be able to match it
up with
the bose so once you consider all of
that if you're an ios user i would say
yeah it probably is worth the extra
money
for the airpods the active noise
cancellation is better
the ambient mode is quite a bit better
and they just work
really well in the apple ecosystem now
with that said
if you're somebody that is using android
i would say i would probably go with the
bose as long as you're not listening to
rock or something that
is very taxing on these headphones
because with that you're not going to
get
most of the main extra features and
bonuses with the airpods
and the active noise cancellation and
the sound is still
very good with these bows but you guys
let me know your
thoughts down in the comments section
below did anything really surprise you i
want to hear your guys's opinions
click that circle above and help us
reach 550k before the end of the year
that would be amazing
and check out one of those awesome
videos right over there
that's been max and i'll see you in the
next video